peut-être le début d'une nouvelle ère
pour les relations sino-américaines
au lendemain de l'investiture de joe
biden la chine a félicité le démocrate
pour son accession à la maison blanche
après quatre ans de rapports houleux
avec l'administration trump l'heure est
à l'apaisement au moins côté chinois
très attentif au message venant de
washington pékin mis sur une coopération
entre les deux puissances
le président biden a insisté dans son
discours sur le mot unité c'est
exactement ce dont nous avons besoin
actuellement dans la relation sino
américaine
tout est possible avec de la
détermination je crois que si les deux
parties coopèrent les anges
l'emporteront sur les forces du mal dans
la relations chine usa les rapports
sino-américains sont tombées au plus bas
sous la présidence de donald trump qui a
engagé dès 2018 une guerre commerciale
et technologique contre le géant
asiatique
un conflit marqué par l'instauration de
taxes douanières américaines sur de
nombreux produits chinois reconstruire
un dialogue s'inscrit donc comme l'une
des priorités du mandat de joe biden
tony blinken nouveau chef de la
diplomatie a rappelé que le renforcement
de la position américaine face à pékin
devait passer par une autre attitude
vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
nous devons commencer par traiter avec
la chine dans une position de force et
non de faiblesse et la bonne nouvelle
est que notre capacité à le faire est
largement sous notre contrôle
la position de force intervient lorsque
nous travaillons à ne pas dénigrer nos
alliés c'est une source de force pour
nous dans nos relations avec la chine
si la nouvelle administration américaine
pourrait se montrer moins provocatrice à
l'égard de la chine
les sujets de discorde entre les deux
pays demeurent taiwan hong kong si niang
pendant sa campagne
joe biden a notamment annoncé qu'il se
montrerait plus ferme avec pékin au
sujet des droits de l'homme